une équipe franco britannique de
scientifiques déchiffrer le code
génétique de la tuberculose on sait donc
maintenant exactement qui est le bacille
de coke
le jean daniel flaysakier et jacques
gregor à l'institut pasteur pendant les
travaux et recherches continuent
aujourd'hui les chercheurs historiens
annoncent qu'ils viennent de réussir un
joli hold ils ont en effet réussi à
décoder tout le patrimoine génétique du
bacille de koch responsable de la
tuberculose
tout le programme de fonctionnement de
ce bacille que l'on voit ici grossi des
centaines de milliers de fois est
désormais connue cette découverte aura
deux impacts d'abord développer un
vaccin beaucoup plus efficace que le bcg
mais surtout mettre au point des
traitements plus rapidement actif que
celui utilisé actuellement le traitement
de la tuberculose est extrêmement longue
et ça c'est un des problèmes majeurs que
le traitement dieu si - donc un de nos
objectifs principaux est de mettre au
point des antibiotiques qui agirait de
manière plus efficace et plus rapide
un traitement plus court serait en effet
plus facile à faire accepter aux
victimes de ce bacille qui tue trois
millions de personnes dans le monde et
près d'un millier par an en france